look what they've sent us and look what
that tells us about our opponents so
what do they tell you basically in the
emo he's sending me that the topics of
discussion yeah is um no no first of all
[Music]
um
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
so it's just one past midnight and we
have come to do this video and we're
going to tell you why I want to give you
guys maybe an analogy imagine you are
being offered a fight Habib and Andrew
Tate you guys are Fighters imagine your
opponent tells you that you are going to
fight them but your hands have to be
tied behind their back and the sponsors
and organizers of this event are all a
part of this so is a referee at one
moment of time you're going to be asking
a question
is why do you require me to have my
hands tied behind my back while you have
gloves on
and this tells you or tells us more
about our opponents and the organizers
and even the referee it says a lot about
them now this is in the sense of a
fight but this is an intellectual battle
here yeah yeah so brothers and sisters
value treatment Patrick Pat David is
that his name
yeah bet okay okay so
I don't really know for that matter you
have seen some of his videos
um I've seen some of your videos which
you um you know correct them irritable
some matters and I had my perceptions
about him and I thought maybe I'm maybe
jumping the gun let's give him a chance
Etc because recently he has been trying
to kind of Outreach to uh khabib and yes
so we thought you know what Muslim
people exactly so we thought okay it's
been good with them exactly so here is
what happened guys when it comes to the
title of the video which is we were
about to be ambushed but we ambushed the
Ambush how because we was invited myself
individually I've got an email you got
an email from valuetainment and we were
speaking to an individual called Robert
and this these negotiations have been
taking place so I'll say overall two
months now yes there was first
initiation that they sent an email yeah
then they went silent no problem because
I'll be honest with you I'm not really
fussed about going there I'll be very
very honest and blunt it's it's the
least of my concern
um so we got this email the first email
was what hijab what was the first thing
that they sent you it was an invitation
I do actually want to kind of read it
out because I don't wanna I don't want
to misrepresent it right so okay so you
open it inshallah so this is we
initially got a couple of months ago a
message then they went silent then they
messaged us about a couple of weeks
before that and they said that they want
to invite me and Mohammed hijab they
want to fly us to fly us out to Florida
and here is what they said the
discussion is going to be about yeah so
in the beginning it says look Patrick
would like to do a round table
discussion on religion specifically
Islam Christianity and Judaism okay so
now
in the beginning we did think this is
going to be a discussion right yes about
Islam Christianity in Judaism the
abrahamic religions yeah building
bridges yeah and then and then the whole
idea of a debate came up right okay
let's have a debate between two Muslims
and two Christians okay yes and let's
let's review who the Christians are and
people may know who they are I mean one
of them is really unknown
um in the English speaking world one of
them is called Robert Spencer yes okay
and the other one is called yes
I don't know his full name in in English
right it's a Christian you know an
anti-muslim figure in the arabic
speaking World arabic speaking people
may know he is in English speak mode is
pretty much unknown right so these two
individuals right we've got a debate
going on two Muslims two Christians it's
already been said to us we're going to
talk about Islam Christianity in Judaism
so this is fantastic we're Debaters
we've been debating for a very long time
we have a range of debates what we do I
mean uh sporadic debates informal
debates formal debates all those kind of
things I don't know 10 years or
something right so it's no news to us we
look at their works so we we prepare
unkind and we we go for it it's gonna be
a two and two debate and it was going to
take place uh on the 21st of September
life actually on his on his platform
exactly and we was looking forward to it
until I said to hijab you know what why
don't you ask them yes what I had
already asked two or three times before
exactly and so I kept asking look you
know you traditionally and
conventionally when you do it about what
you need to do you just have the
structure in place yes these are like
you're going to speak for this long
you're going to speak for that long
whatever and these are the topics and
this was not gonna Veer off from the
topic that's what happens so how many
times did we have to I asked about four
times four times effectively four times
so check this out guys we asked once no
reply we asked the second times second
time no reply third time no reply the
fourth time and uh and it's important to
note here yeah as we're getting closer
and closer to the discussion so I have
reason to believe
symmetry in the way that the information
has been distributed in it because let's
think about it what would you expect
Patrick has already shown anti-islamic
bias yeah we've got so many very videos
on my channel I don't I don't need to
you know mention it here not every
Muslim is a terrorist but every
terrorist yeah all that stuff he's
corrected some of it but still he's got
anti-islamic bias and he's a Christian
himself yes no problem so you've got
these Christians okay you've got anti
and then to add insult to injury this is
what happened he comes today and I said
what is the topic okay it's not going to
be a topic it's not going to be timed
listen carefully this okay let me let me
read out because once again I don't want
to misrepresent it yes read it out okay
so so this is what I'm hearing right
yeah before before you read it out bear
in mind who is our opponent Robert
Spencer Robert Spencer is somebody who
has been banned from the United Kingdom
Robert Spencer is somebody who and this
brevik in his Manifesto when he killed
70 plus individuals I'll repeat it again
he slaughtered 70 plus individuals and
put a bomb in a parliament building and
in its Manifesto this is actually Robert
Spencer's student
yes
he in his Manifesto mentions Robert
Spencer and encourages people Spencer
right yes so now imagine for a second
would Patrick Pat Davidson yes that's
his name yeah yeah please I genuinely do
not remember yeah David yeah imagine for
a moment that Isis went and carried out
an atrocity killing non-muslims and in
that Manifesto they say that he was
inspired by Ali dawa go read his books
what no by the way he didn't say Inspire
just to be clear no problem okay not
inspired but he he recommends I
recommend any that was videos they're
very good no problem all I said all of
them all of them all of them all of them
would I be invited that platform would I
be let in
the United States so that is an insult
already for you to invite them it's
number four yeah that's right who is
known by yeah by the way that's right
he's got a Jihad watch and the very
funny thing is he's a case studying
himself absolutely you have been used by
a terrorist and not only that we thought
you know what no problem we'll smash him
yeah because we have no problem we do
this on a daily basis but look what
they've sent us and look what that tells
us about our opponents so what did they
tell you basically an email he's sending
me that the topics of discussion yeah is
um first of all it wouldn't be
structured it wouldn't be structured
debate yeah okay so remember you've got
a pet David who's already an individual
who's uh you know showing his
anti-slamic bias he's going to be the
moderator no problem because we we think
and I still do believe this by the way
yes I'll put it to him yeah I do think
he's got that bit of Honor about him yes
okay so that he's he's magnanimous he's
respectful he's honor honorable you know
I do think that because you know at the
end of the day to be fair to him again
he was going to invite us with his own
money like his value so let me tell you
however however having said that yeah
he's saying
it's not going to be structured
it's going to be a Roundtable discussion
yeah okay no problem uh there's not
gonna be any timing no debate structure
which means that there can be an
equality here there can be uh
arbitrariness no problem okay okay but
then listen the podcast will be will
focused on listen to follow Islam the
Quran the teachings of Muhammad three
things Christianity no there's no
mention nothing and may of include other
topics such as the importance of
interphase Islamic apologetics
islamophobia like May keywords or
anything may I don't even regard me the
three things I mentioned Islam teachings
of Muhammad Quran so what is this in
order for you to try and deal with us
you need to like you mentioned in the
beginning
but the things were even dangerous when
you tired we would come the issue is
this at hand it's an insult it's
offensive do you think we are is it
themselves
do you think we are yeah mugs yeah you
think I'm an idiot that I'm going to
come there at the cost of My Religion
we're going to reinterrogate it
interrogated by
these uh things in place that I can't
even defend my region do you think
whoever you're not sorry let me add
something here bro yeah okay can you
imagine what kind of fragility and
insecurity that is required here bro in
order for someone to say this to you
like imagine it's like you said bro
imagine someone saying to you I'm gonna
fight you here yes but you can't fight
me back he tells me a lot about my
opponent yeah that means you have no
confidence in your religion bro give us
10 minutes bro 10 minutes give us 10
minutes we'll Flat Line the whole of
Christianity and they know that it'll be
like Jenga you know Jenga when you play
or like a house of cards the whole thing
will be broken give me 10 minutes and
I'll disprove Christianity but you know
the moment I start speaking about
Christianity you're gonna be on Shaky
Ground exactly you're gonna be on Shaky
Ground and I believe look Pat is a
businessman yes that's his Forte that's
what he deals with yeah I don't believe
this came from him I believe this came
from Robert of course because you know
what do you know the evidence of that
yes the evidence of that if you look at
these guys and I've seen his debates at
the Rashid guy yeah but look at the
titles of his debates
is the is the Quran the words of Allah
is uh the Islam the religion of his uh
salaam is the illusion of Peace it's all
about Islam why are you so scared of
making an inequal debate where you're
discussing Islam and other religion
scarcely seldomly irregularly do you
ever do that because you're coward
you're coward you don't want to put your
neck on intellectual Tropic that's the
reason that's the reason why same thing
with Robert Spencer exactly if this
didn't come from Pat I believe this came
from them because they November it tells
me a lot about my opponent imagine if
they say that the fact that you're not
so scared to do with your own religion
and put on table the fact that and this
is not a new phenomenon
speakers
it's horrible they all they talk about
is the Quran that's right they don't
talk about the look this is the
scripture that was told by Paul to God
Owen preach to the world exactly and the
only thing you preaching to the word is
the Quran so the point is what in a
nutshell we are not going to be bought
by money even if you said to us 10
million pounds yeah they will send you
account do you think
10 million dollars
[Laughter]
you think about cheap individuals we're
going to come there at the cost of our
religion no way
listen we're negotiating on behalf of
the community
listen to us whoever is whoever is
behind this moreover
inside anywhere here bro who's this
Rasheed hijabi who's expensive yeah
one second
the point I'm saying is the following
yes they don't know who this man here is
one second have you not seen America
the point is the following problem yeah
and since you were watching this yeah
yeah that's we to us our religion is
more dear than any kind of money that's
when you're gonna come there to have
some money now pocket if they were to
offer that and we're going to come then
you're going to demonize our religion
and make our religion exactly so we're
going to be we're going to be
interrogated you've come to the wrong
people wrong things all they're going to
say is the following yeah Patrick you
can
you can fix this how you can fix this
tell them how number one we reject your
offer to come to Florida reject it
outright rejected rejected that's number
one number two you can forget about
after this insult yeah after this insult
this offensive insult after you've
spoken to khabib and you take you on
Muslims and I'm talking to Andrew Tate
and Habib yes we have connections as
well we will send this video to them
because this shows either maliciousness
if this came from you I do not ever want
to come to your platform if this came
from our cowardly opponents who cannot
speak about it because if it came from
them then you know what I'll see yeah
you know what we don't blame you it came
from them and you're just communicating
what they said then we would maybe maybe
come to Florida and Miami to have a
discussion with him with you yeah yeah
we're not speaking to individuals who
have blood on their hands
yes that's all we have to say I still
want to debate it's got to be equal
stuff exactly
there is no debate yeah they're showing
their cowardness Yeah by by saying that
we can if there is
the reason we've done this video guys is
to show you sadly sadly when we want to
build Bridges that's right look we love
the Jews Christians Muslims this time
together let's talk about common the
stuff that we have that's not the
dialogue the fact that it went from
Christianity Islam and Judaism open
discussion yeah to bring into hostile
islamophobes and then you can't speak
about their own and then we cannot speak
about them I should say something we
even require a public apology not to us
to the Muslims Community yeah yeah
absolutely that's all I'm going to say
anything else you want to say bro I
think you summarized it very well and
I'll say to look this is actually
embarrassing this is actually
embarrassing because like you said bro
if I said to someone look I want to
discuss imagine I come to a Christian or
a feminist or whatever it is let's
discuss feminism or Christianity or
whatever yeah but you're not allowed to
speak to me about my worldview at all
but it's International saying I can
punch you in the face and your hands are
you cannot touch me bro do you know how
cowardly that is that is that is the
epitome of cowardice yes with that we
conclude was
exactly Islam that is establishing a
Masjid and a community center if you
donate to build a semester Allah will
inshallah build a house for you in
Jannah with bricks of gold and silver
every person who prays in this Masjid
every child that memorized the Quran you
will inshallah sharing that reward
donate it now guys and do not delay
foreign